Tech titans appeared on Capitol Hill, albeit remotely,...
...to face lawmakers in a much-anticipated hearing on antitrust concerns.
Members of both parties at the House judiciary subcommittee hearing on Wednesday...
...grilled the four CEOs: Apple's Tim Cook, Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg,..
...Alphabet's Sundar Pichai and Amazon's Jeff Bezos...
...on everything from market dominance to data surveillance...
...to military contracts to political censorship.
Simply put, they have too much power.
This power staves off new forms of competition, creativity and innovation.
The four men, who together represent about 5 trillion dollars of the US economy,...
...faced accusations of abusing their immense power to maintain dominance.
Democrats wanted assurances that Facebook would police hate speech and misinformation...
...in the hopes of preventing a repeat of the kind of foreign election interference...
...the U.S. saw in 2016.
While Republicans like ranking member Jim Jordan said the real election interference...
...was social media companies purportedly targeting conservatives.